welcome back everyone okay so we're
talking about data-driven modeling and
control and in particular now we're
gonna start talking about machine
learning for control okay so I just want
to recall this basic generalized
feedback control diagram here you have
some dynamical system
maybe it's complex nonlinear multi scale
high dimensional there are some
disturbances to your system maybe a gust
of wind or something unmeasurable
parameters that change the dynamics
there's some high-level objective
function that you want to optimize
either minimize or maximize and the idea
is to design some control law based on
sensor measurements of your system that
can then drive the system through
actuation through your control knobs so
this is kind of the generic architecture
that we've been working with from day
one even back in the control bootcamp
and what we've been talking about is how
to use data-driven methods machine
learning and other types of optimization
both to design the dynamical system and
the controller so we spend a lot of time
talking about how you would use machine
learning for characterizing your
dynamical system this is essentially
system identification but with modern
methods in data-driven optimization and
our machine learning so you can spend a
lot of time and effort characterizing
your system from data and then use that
system model to design a control law but
what we're going to talk about today is
instead of painstakingly characterizing
your system dynamics just to design a
control law instead what we're going to
do is use these statistical and machine
learning optimizations directly to
design effective control laws that you
can then wrap around some unknown
dynamical system so some of the
motivation for this is the following so
dynamics are hard to characterize and it
turns out that in a lot of cases the
model that you need to predict and
understand a physical system is a lot
more sophisticated than the model you
need to control the system okay so we
spend a lot of time understanding the
dynamics getting a model that's you know
really good description of the physical
system that might be overkill for a
control lock we have robust control
can handle a lot of model uncertainty
and missing dynamics so spending a lot
of effort on dynamical system modeling
might not be the best use of time in
addition the whole point of this is to
measure the system and then drive it to
change the dynamics okay so if I have
something like a rocket ship I'm
thinking of like the Blue Origin or
SpaceX rocket that they're gonna land
back on the launch pad or on a moving
platform at sea then I'm trying to
change my natural system dynamics which
are unstable and I'm trying to drive
them to be stable dynamics so if I spend
all this time characterizing my system
it might be that right when I apply the
control the dynamics change a lot and I
observe new phenomenon that I never saw
before this is especially true in very
complex high dimensional nonlinear
systems like you know political systems
or financial markets or disease modeling
where even if I have a great model of
the natural unforced system when I start
to apply control if I start to make a
regulatory policy or a vaccination
campaign I might dramatically change the
dynamics and start to see phenomena that
I never saw before and my dynamic model
might very rapidly break down and start
being useless for control so instead of
putting all of that energy into the
dynamics modeling which you know I
actually do like modeling dynamics maybe
we should be spending more effort
directly trying to design effective
control laws using data and so this is
largely inspired by the fact that in
modern systems of interest it might
actually be possible to try lots of
control laws to gather lots of data so
the example that that we've been
thinking about this is with
collaborators like Baron Nowak and
others are turbulence control problems
so that's a very very challenging
dynamical system a turbulent fluid high
dimensional hard to model very hard to
design reduced order models that are
suitable for control people have spent
decades trying to do this and it's very
very challenging but in modern
experiments you can try a control law
you can try you could write down a
controller that you think might work and
you can try it in an experiment in a
wind tunnel or a water channel in
something like
seconds or half a minute okay so in that
short of an amount of time you might
actually know if your controller was or
was not effective at optimizing your
objective function and so with that kind
of a scale you might be able to apply
hundreds or thousands of different
control laws and use this data-driven
optimization this machine learning
architecture to go from kind of this
broad sweep the shotgun approach of many
candidate control laws and start
refining them into these very very
highly effective control laws through
optimization so that's kind of the idea
that lots of these systems of interest
you can directly optimize your control
law if you have a good parameterization
of controller space if you have some
good set of parameters that define what
families of controllers you can try you
can run data-driven machine learning
optimizations directly on those
controllers and then wrap that around
your system now this doesn't necessarily
work for lots of systems of interests so
for example I don't want to do this in
disease modeling because there are
ethical concerns with trying a thousand
candidate control laws knowing that a
lot of them are not going to be very
effective so that's actually a case
where I might want a physical model so
that I don't waste energy and time and
hurt people trying you know to refine my
control law through trial and error
through kind of an optimized fancy trial
and error another example would be I
think like neural control like if you're
trying to stop someone's seizures you're
probably not going to do a trial and
error based based control strategy so a
nuclear reactor okay I'm trying to
control some fusion reactors some
tokamak probably I don't want to do
trial and error you know try a thousand
bad controllers where this thing might
blow up just to find the one the one
good one okay but what you might do is
you might build a proxy model using kind
of machine learning up here and then if
you had that proxy model then in
simulation you could try this
machine learning control optimization
approach without actually put in any
humans at risk okay I hope that was
clear so lots of options here what I
would advocate where we're moving in the
future in the next you know five 10 20
years is really putting this brain kind
of in the middle and doing this hybrid
approach where you
your dynamics and you learn your control
law in concert and that's much more like
what humans do where you have some
physical model of the world where you
can run these simulations so for example
if I'm trying to play tennis I have some
basic physics simulator in my head that
tells me what I think should happen
depending on what my control input is
and so in the background I can be
running this kind of optimization to
figure out better and better control
laws and then periodically I go play
tennis and I actually can refine my
strategy with real data and I can refine
my model and my control I in in real
time okay
so that's where things are going right
now we're going to zoom in on on how to
use machine learning for the control
okay that's what we're going to talk
about for the next the next few lectures
in particular one of the things that I
think is really interesting and exciting
is the use of evolutionary algorithms
and genetic algorithms for control so
you have this is kind of a generic
diagram like before I had my dynamical
system I have my control loss on cost
function J and what I'm doing is I'm
running this meta learning algorithm
this genetic programming algorithm where
I try lots of different control laws but
then I learn an effective control law
after this kind of targeted optimized
trial and error procedure over time and
so I'm going to tell you a lot about
genetic algorithms genetic programming
and how you use those for control we're
going to cook up a few simple examples
in MATLAB for things like PID control
I'm going to tell you how this has been
used for turbulence control but in
general you can also do you can do lots
more than this I can have instead of
this genetic programming optimization I
could build a neural network okay so I
could have this kind of neural network
model that is that's driving my
dynamical system or I could maybe in
some cases I have a very complex cost
landscape J the example I like to think
of is if I'm playing chess how do you
know what a good board position is
that's kind of your cost function J how
do I know it at an instant how good J is
that's a very subjective and difficult
to measure measure quantity so I might
actually use neural networks to learn
what my cost landscape is and then I can
use something like reinforcement
learning
or model predictive control once I know
something better about my system or my J
okay and so that's what people are doing
now with deep reinforcement learning and
deep model predictive control is
essentially they're using you know deep
neural networks for the hard to model
parts of those control laws which in
reinforcement learning it's this kind of
objective function this value function
landscape and so that's another another
thing you can do there's tons of options
again I just want to harp on this
because it's so important
control is optimization that's
constrained by the dynamics machine
learning is optimization based on data
and the really interesting control
problems are nonlinear optimizations and
fortunately machine learning is giving
us better and better non-linear
optimization techniques based on the
wealth of data we can collect so that's
what we're gonna be doing we're going to
be talking about how to essentially use
machine learning and data-driven
optimization directly to find good
control laws without needing models of
the dynamics okay so that's all coming
up next we're going to talk about
genetic algorithms genetic programming
and some applications okay thank you